oh he's ready for a drink
rude always the in fits of giggles some
random man and a big red onesie why why
so you just got all about nonsense about
we're kicking things off in season 5
with a very romantic episode of course
Bri and Rogers wedding and we need to
get the fans ready for that episode so
we're gonna play a little game as we
always do okay great it's called
something old new borrowed and blue okay
first question
something old tell me your all-time
favorite Outlander episode I don't know
this is a couple name of couple well
from season 1 episode 1 just because it
was the beginning you have to say the
wedding episode of forest and then
season 2 faith but also when Claire
returns
I think that was episode 11 or 12 12
most binax know with the third see you
can't even remember them I think was the
finale
I don't remember 50 years guys 60 years
and then season 3 episode 3 I loved all
of the like Claire and Frank stuff it
was really amazing and then and then the
reunion so yeah there you go ooh episode
4 yeah when they go out and they're the
rent is it the rent party next is the
first time what we all like got together
as a big big band of merry men and yeah
there's a few of them here tonight you
can name a couple your on-screen mama
patrina named quite a few I've fair
enough I mean from personal I love
working with Tobias oh I love down the
rabbit hole I love the ones where you
see Claire and Bree together which I
think it's like 305 when Brianna kind of
becomes the mother and since flyback
because that relationship really starts
to bond I'm gonna say the wedding
episode because that will make everybody
very happy which is one oh I don't know
what
one of them 107 you mean why 107 107
Blair Jaime 501 yours I know because I
just watched it because it's drought
Lander it's probably still the end of
season 1 I love the work of Tobias and
Sam and episode it's it's it's really um
yeah it was just there was no when her
passions it was reached a really really
amazing acting between the two of them
and I love them as actors anyway and I
just loved I just loved how bold it was
how raw and true it was and I mean we've
had many many really great episodes
sense but that's one that really kind of
webs on with me all the time
something new give me a tease about
season five what are you most excited
for fans to see this season is so tough
because there's so many great episodes
six seven and eight are fantastic but I
think the finales are best finale yet
you know I'm there's so much this season
obviously it's really an amazing start
with the wedding it just feels really
sweet and lovely and everyone's having a
great time and it all goes the way of
Outlander then it's Outlander um there
are some unwelcome characters who come
back in season five and I think episode
10 is a very good Roger and Jamie's
relationship of blossom into something
beautiful
love me duck please love me back love me
dot
I'm trying real hard Something Borrowed
what does the habit you've picked up
from one of your co-stars from a co-star
and Kachinas foot tap she's ready for a
drink I wish I could say I'd picked up
some habit for the gym but that just
does not seem to rubbed off on me at all
I think he picked up your whiskey habit
I think he had already hadn't been with
me hovered in fairness I don't know mean
Sophie go to yoga all the time so maybe
maybe yeah I picked up her habit of
going to yoga I don't know
Frank I suppose Katrina and Sam can be
little Frank stirs so now we all just
stir in on the game that's a tricky
question probably eating a lot of
protein bars oh excuse me I'm sorry
thanks for apologizing that's all we
needed Thank You Lauren Layla villain
the best no the best she's a nuisance I
love her tell me a lot of time you were
laughing so hard on set you turned blue
in the face it's not me turning blue is
Katrina turning blue there's many many
times that she will now just literally
turn her back if she's laughing and you
have to carry on the scene with her with
her back to you but um yeah she's the
one that goes blue oh gods one of my
knots there was there was one scene in
season four we were on the pier
I mean the season three on the pier I
don't know there was a man in a red
onesie sort of watching us and I I just
couldn't stop I was just I don't know
what it was was just some random man and
a big red onesie why like in the middle
of winter and it wasn't Santa I don't
know it's just thought very odd did it
tickle to me for some reason
I mean usually blue in the face on a
lender is because you're freezing but
laughing in the pit okay so David I
always had so much fun filming with
David we would always be in fits of
giggles and actually I think maybe that
the the dinner scene with Captain Forbes
in everyone and it was just so hilarious
at Jack Astor's they're sort of where
she's serenading all the gentlemen in
front of Rihanna that scene was
hilarious to shoot and there's actually
probably a lot of outtakes of David and
I just giggling in the corner like
little kids definitely blue in the face
with Helen there's been a few occasions
know about one of the one that springs
to mind as in season two
are you shafted me over
where's my camera technique went out the
window without laughs Wayne season 2
with us a road trip with Briana and I
were Sophie and I and they weren't
recording audio they were just recording
us driving so it was on a low order and
they were shooting us through the window
and we were just talking utter nonsense
the most hypothetical useless nonsense
but we were in stitches laughing for
like the entire day and there was one
point where we drove down to where Rajon
Briana have a picnic at the end of
season 2 done by Laura caption and we
hadn't realized the cameras had started
rolling and for some reason we were
talking about whether whether a dead
body was blue or whether it would sink
in the river and I was adamant it would
blow up eventually but anyway the whole
conversation was just so ridiculous and
we hadn't realized they were turning
over on it they were filming it and Matt
Roberts was directing that day and he
was like oh maybe they'll just improvise
in their way and at the scene maybe this
is just what they do you know they
weren't really familiar with us as
actors and he came over me knocked on
the window and he said you guys realized
that what the bellman right and we were
like what so you just got all about
nonsense about it it was bizarre it was
a really really bizarre but really
morbidly funny day on set
[Music]